as the rays and the marlins square off
the rays
seven games up in the american league
east over the boston red sox the raids
magic number
stands at two
tonight for the tampa bay devil rays it
will be shane mcclanahan making his 24th
start of the season looking for that
10th win he's had an outstanding rookie
campaign 115 in the third innings 135
strikeouts and that e.r.a
had just over three and a half
49 runs batted in a ground ball that's a
diving stop lal will skip it in they got
him
nice play over there by brandon wow
on the stop and then on that throw to
first to skip it in to joy
to get chism and ready to go the 3-2
pitch runners go swinging a ground ball
towards short diving stop wendell has to
get up and hurry his throw is just in
time at first base
to retire the side
a couple of real nice defensive plays
for the rays
as they flash the leather
on a couple of occasions and deny the
marlins here in the top of the first
they leave a couple of base runners
30-second start of the season for sandy
alcatra that matches his career high
from 2019.
meadows rolls one to first and leigh
diaz is there steps on the bag and sandy
is through one
and eddie alvarez gets to it spins and
makes the play all right good defense on
both sides tonight
strikeout for alcantara his first of the
game that one on eight pitches gonna be
the top of the order for the marlins
here in the top of the third we're
scoreless in saint petersburg ground out
to third is first time up and this one
is hit well and deep out to left field
and that's gone a home run for miguel
rojas
just enough to clear the wall to left
field and get the marlins on the board
one nothing
yeah the marlins get their first lead in
tampa bay
leaning on miggy row to get it done
there's a cut miss right there on the
slider
swinging again to miss on that fastball
up he got him to chase 98 there
the 23rd pitch of the night the 02 swing
and a miss he's got his second strikeout
he's either catching running around the
bases or
well that's it that's that's all it
would be yeah
maybe makes a strikeout in here
two balls two strikes here comes got him
swinging on a high fast ball
he strikes out his third batter alvarez
retired two-hour runner at second leaves
it for sandy leone
tapper down to third
diaz gloves and throws and
joy keeps that foot on the back to
retire the side with a man left
getting closer to 200 strikeouts that's
number four
center field that ball is going to be in
there extra bases
bounding to the wall meadows on his way
to second he's going to dig for three
he's going to make it he is safe for
third base
third triple of the year for meadows
wendell can pull the baseball here very
likely
and a base hit just to the right of
alvarez up the left-field line
grazer tied it meadows has scored
wendell in its second with a stand-up
double
i i'm kind of surprised that you would
concede that run and play that if you
just give it to the raise now here oh
joey wendell ends up taking a mistake
breaking ball and shooting it by alvarez
for a double to left field
2-2 pitches swinging a miss he's able to
strike out kiermeier to get out of this
hitting let's punch out number five for
sandy
next pitchers are swinging a grounder
right side off the glove
of the second baseman chism and into
center field for what might be a base
hit could also be an e4 that's a play
that probably needed to be made a lead
off base runners with speed now mike
zanino at the plate
he drives it into deep right center
well tagged and that ball is gone
mike cenino gives the raise the lead
with his 32nd home run of the year
what a year he is having
32 home runs
up the middle lau
can't get a handle on it
and sanchez beats it out
lewis grinson
ground ball base it up the middle
now they made a bid for a hit back in
the first inning but wendell made a
great play on him and uh blue is staying
up the middle there hitting another one
sharply and
arnold's had the tying runs aboard in
the sixth
ground ball through for a base hit here
comes sanchez and a late red light for
trey hillman when the marlins have the
base is loaded in one out
alvarez to the right side lao gets the
out at second that's all they'll get
now run comes in to score it's a one-run
game once again brandon lau flashing the
leather
over at second base
runner breaks a swing and a miss
that takes care of leon he's out on
strikes
miami settles for one ray's lead 3-2
that's a tapper up the third base side
fair
alvarez got to it lost it recovers and
the throat is second that ball is going
to go into right field but backed up by
sanchez
and wendell stays at second base
and now here's johnny diaz trying to get
that raised run back
there's a base hit into center
that will get wendell home and the raise
again lead by two
so yandy diaz
rbi number 61.
and this is into right and it's going to
one-hop the wall
jazz will cruise into second with a
double
you know this is a slider and jazz is
right on it maybe out in front just a
little bit but kept it fair here's brian
de la cruz two for three tonight
that is a base hit another three hit day
jazz rounding third here's the throw
it's late jazz tumbles in with
the third run
all right the breaking ball stays up de
la cruz right on it rips it into left
ground ball that's going to chop through
the right side
diaz the only man over there
and there's a base hit i'll tell you
he's hitting home runs and hitting the
ball the other way now
got a lead off single here in the
seventh inning and up steps brandon loud
into right center field
in there for extra bases a couple of
hops to the bottom of the wall zenino's
gonna be waved around third
here comes the throw and he is safe
double
for lau and the raids tack on another
run
again up by two
a called strike three
for objecting to the call third strike
manny gonzalez ejected him
and just moments later with don
mattingly coming out
mattingly didn't like the idea that
alvarez had been ejected and
gonzalez ejected mattingly
and there's a liner into right
caught
out there by sanchez
runner will score from third as diaz
crosses the plate
and turmeyer advances second to third
and the rays now make it 6-3
and now with two out here brandon loud
wow fair ball up the left-field eye
that will get caremeyer in
extra bases
in the second base brandon lau with his
third double of the night
drives in his second run and it's 7-3
[Music]
the one thing they have never done is
clinch the american league east at home
and they're about to do it in front of a
sold-out crowd on a saturday night with
two outs the marlins have loaded the
bases fair makes ready to go to pitch
and he goes to the fastball gets the
pop-up
joy under it and the rays are the chance
in the american league east
the rays have gone back to back as ali's
division champs they are once again
the beast of the east as they are your
american the yeast
2021 champions
you